[Music]
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk we got a we got a hot guest he's
on his way in from across the pond I
don't want to give anything away all
over the states too he's uh he's hanging
oh he's International you look at those
day we think we're cool it's like hey
Australia Cleveland this guy is
Munich North Pole Wuhan Hamas you name
it that's not a place place I was going
to say this from the sea to the ocean
whatever the hell the term is what is it
from the sea to the [__] I can't
remember C-section who
knows from the river the river to hell's
going on here all right all right
Meanwhile we're sitting with the King of
New York here no no oh that's right just
played MSG coming off MSG theater it was
fun it's a fun night man it was hell
yeah went to the out got to see the
Knicks locker room the Rangers locker
room it had the catering in cuz pink was
playing the big room so it was like
catering in the just like hanging by
Jaylen brunson's locker and there's like
tuna subs and [__] nice but uh yeah it
was crazy man it was it was fun fun
night Marlin craft your boy did a set he
was great musician Marlin craft Soulful
Jazz rap love it oh love that so New
York wears a Walt Clyde Frasier Jersey
on stage then we got uh you know Joe
list and Willl s vined sets hey hey yeah
and then uh ooh a wild night had a crazy
ex tossed from
the the one wait a minute you had an
ex-girlfriend tossed from the show 16
years ago I knew it was her heckling I
didn't say she was heckling yeah crazy X
is the key here yeah yeah what a win
though your ex gets to see you at a
soldout garden you do a bit she gets
it's not a win cuz I'm going have to get
a restraining order it's not oh it's
that crazy it's you there are times when
you're young where you're like well
maybe this won't work out but not to
that extent man you don't think like
maybe I'll have to show a judge text
messages right you just think maybe I'll
have to see other people sure but other
judges I made out with a girl in front
of my ex once that to me I thought that
was a win though but this is pretty good
it's not a win it's it's a lot walk me
through getting her removed my agent
well my agent no I I have a joke I had a
long bit about her I didn't do out of
respect cuz she sent me a million texts
I didn't answer saying I'm coming with
my mom so I'm like all right let me not
let me not do this bit and then um I do
a joke that's not even about her
obviously but I say well I guess she
could assume it's about her but it's not
I say you know I've never dated a woman
with a good father that's the setup and
she goes hey oh my God hey so I knew it
was her hey I'm like that so I kind of
diffuse it pretty quickly I'm being like
am I getting heckled by a [__]
manate and uh and I'm just trashing her
and whatever and burtz my agent who's
you know he's a shark he runs out to and
goes shut the [__] up W and they're like
they're like you know blown away and he
goes if you don't sh if you don't leave
right now you'll be arrested and she
goes who are you and he goes Paul he
made up a backstory as a security guard
and uh he goes my name is Paul and then
I guess he nodded to another security
security guard my lawyer just two
medium-sized Jews yeah but uh MSG
security threw me out a long message
whatever and uh do you have a code you
know get uh get a drink or whatever no
that's I think D roa's code yeah I think
that's a standard get this person a
drink no and also I didn't even do it I
was just annoyed cuz I was like GH this
just like I just let me just get to this
bit Yeah so I just usually I'll
entertain a Heckler and I'll [__]
slam him but I was like I know who this
is they're not right in the head this is
going to go badly so what's the mom
doing is the mom going sh I think
apologizing for okay at least the mom's
saying I
mean yeah it was it was nutty but yeah
the night as a whole was was killer you
know the seller staff was there asy
gnome Val Liz everyone uh yeah wild
night really fun I I puked nice I think
it's I didn't drink that much I think
it's a combo of the booze and the stress
levels but uh yeah I was I was down for
the C it was it was multiple middle of
the night wakeup pukes which that's
always unpleasant damn I haven't had one
of those in years it was rough yeah it
wasn't good so now you got no sleep and
you're yaking
not good yeah rough rough Sunday but
what are you gonna do I'm having
Nas yes for Pride I'm so proud I feel so
good you played the [__] left my body
that night Jesus Christ what the hell
you using I hope a parag glider comes in
and shoots you Jesus Christ what the
hell was that anyway I'm really I'm
really
overed that was a fun night it was cool
it's like cool to see your parents happy
brother and sister didn't come did a
joke about that really cuz they were
running the marathon the next day so I
said my dad writes an email all three of
you have a big weekend I go [__] you
it's my weekend come on hey hey Jimbo
Jimmy join us I believe your luck how
are you how are you
man pleas hey good to see you man
looking sharp yeah know I mean you come
on we might be drunk you you can't dress
up this is huge oh yeah this is my big
break doing the pad run lately I see
yeah I did a couple I mean they're very
fun it's really it's really kind of
interesting thing now where people go
I'd rather do this than you do The
Tonight Show no one calls no I don't
know Joe Rogan or modern wisdom or or
what and like people go oh yeah that's
good oh yeah this is way better it's
more authentic you know we're not just
going to fake laugh and uh you don't
have to sit next to you're not going to
fake laugh we'll give you a go we'll get
the all right you got one the uh yeah
know it's very nice to see boys uh man
it's weird that thing of like the job
that we do as well it's like um I was
like standup comedy is kind of self
assignment right you kind of do it
yourself and you've got all the control
and then there's that weird thing that
happens when you start working with
producers if you you know where you go I
don't know I'm waiting around for
someone to give me permission yes and
then you sort of do the podcast thing
just seems to fit with what Comics are
you go no I'll just do it myself I don't
have a boss no one I remember Bill Burr
when I think when Lou got canceled Bill
Burr s saying well I'm going to cancel
me what are they going to do take away
my
garage my podcast in my garage yeah good
luck fellas it makes sense I mean I had
just had the agent meeting of like
what's next what are you working on
what's your passion I'm like oh I'm
doing it yeah I know that's a bummer but
this is stand up I think it like fits
into that whole thing of like I'm I'm
getting quite stoic in my old age I'm
trying to do less better like just be a
stand up I've been doing that for years
but that thing of like when you're
trying to write a sitcom you're on the
road and you're trying to write some or
a movie or something in the background
you go oh this is taking all of that
mental energy right and the only thing
that's ever grown corn for me is writing
jokes that's how I feel but that's we've
talked about this a lot is you know
sorry no Sor no if it's Bing on no stop
[__] know this guy I agree with what
you're saying but also like I do I grew
up loving movies I do want to do that as
well we're working on a movie we're
working on a movie right now we're
trying to write I don't think I'm not
I've got one I think in pre-production
but I mean but but the side Hustle the
amount of energy that that takes and
meetings and and the they can meet next
month and O they got to meet in two
months and and so now we're waiting two
months before we can even get the whole
business has been on strike it doesn't
feel that different not for a comic it
doesn't for like movies and stuff the
but that that thing as well with the I
think I sort of view those as lottery
tickets right so you're a stand up
that's your job and then the the like
the little side hustle thing of like you
go yeah but I'll I'll throw something in
the ring but you it's not taking a huge
amount of you realize this is your main
job yes that's like a little hobby the
movie business for it's not really our
thing what's the movie about what are
you writing a movie about H we we want
to keep it on the DL for now it's it's
it's a long process here but uh two
girls one cup too yeah right four girls
eight cups insane it's a lot of feces um
the how is that keep itle is that a
reference everyone gets wow it's a very
popular fil yeah sure I don't know if
everyone gets I think like I don't think
my mom would get it but I think she
would just be like oh that's funny I
would like you know I don't think
everyone gets well that's how you test
if it's a good mom if she knows that
movie you're like oh she's [__] the
mailman or whatever yeah if your mom was
in that movie that's someone's Mom
that's someone that's someone's Mom
that's what it feels like well one died
one of the girls this guy's a fan oh
yeah I know the whole you know what's as
well Len to by a lot of people you
realize someone has just had to Google
two girls one cup and what I going oh no
oh they've Googled it it it's one of
those ones where it fills in when you're
right half I could never watch it though
I could never sit through it pull it up
no don't put it up I'm joking I'm joking
ter Wikipedia But one died hang on it
was in your search history see how did
she die shame
presumably presumably shame is actually
I don't know no it's actually had a
shitty di there you Go's the one there
it is yeah um all right you logging off
okay that was a log joke is this uh is
this Dog Day Afternoon or hey I mean
hell of a movie right they were on they
were on trans about what 40 years ahead
of everyone else like Jim Norton and in
a PR like Jim
and and in a pretty Progressive Way like
there aren't jokes about it it's just
kind of like yeah that's who I like
right that looks like me last night it's
uh yeah it's a remarkable movie I read
that movie uh that book actually before
coming on I was like thinking about oh
okay just kind of have recommendations
people talk about movies I read the
Tarantino book uh Cinema speculation
over the summer and I basically stopped
watching new
movies I'm just watching 7s movies now I
really recommend like you go it's the
best decade for for music and for film
and I think it's maybe analogous to what
comedy's doing now because comedy is the
the the companies didn't get involved
like the the corporations didn't get
involved yet so in the 70s it was kind
of Alters doing their thing yes art
without committee let them go that's why
curb is so good just let him go yes he's
got that status where he can do whatever
he wants also late it kind of started
like late 60s I think when you when you
had like Bonnie and Clyde and like The
Graduate and those I would say that all
fits into that kind of that late 60s
early 7s yeah it's kind of great though
and he's like the Tarantino book as well
if you get like the audio book I love
the Audio I mean we spend our lives
traveling so it's just listening but
Tarantino reads the first like five
chapters and it's so you're just caught
up in this guy's like passion it's so
[__] great he's such a nerd he loves
it okay I love it I can listen to him
all day huge fan I heard him talking
about the movie thief the other day and
just just hearing him talk about other
movies he loves like you're right it's
so contagious his passion and and he's
talking about how wet the streets are in
that movie just like oh little things
like that he goes yeah Michael man would
walk around with a water truck and
dampen the streets so it looked like
gritty in Detroit the little things yeah
you kind of would go well why do that
yeah I often think that when they've got
an establishing shot that clearly cost a
fortune you go ah we could have lived
without that right but then it's just a
play but then but then it's a part of
the movie in a way where you're like I
mean I was watching a Woody Allen movie
the other night uh Sweden Lowdown and
you're like just these cars like Woody
Allen movies seem pretty low budget just
these cars in a period piece cost so
[__] much oh yeah detail it's crazy
yes it's weird as well you kind of I
think you can slightly spoil it for
yourself by knowing too much about the
production yeah rather than be kind of
taken away agreed you want to be lost in
it but then you hear about all these
Tarantino weird movie like this Apple
cigarettes and he has all these
connections from movie to movie and you
think does that help the movie or does
that just show how psycho detailed he is
and that's why they're good you see what
I'm saying which one is it did the yeah
he's created a whole world that he us
into like alterate Universe right I mean
that thing about in glorious bastards I
mean spoiler uh but theorious bastards
and the the uh once potin in Hollywood
which I watched and obviously I watched
it as a guy that's I've read a lot about
those murders and so you're watching the
whole thing with this sense of sort of
horrible anxiety about oh what's going
to happen and then it doesn't yeah and
you're kind of it's like the sort of
Genius of it it's a Twist yeah it's like
a bit by way Once Upon a Time in Nazi
Germany was the original title and it
got shorten to Eng glorious bastards and
if you notice in both movies he sort of
makes up the ending like a story like a
story book yeah alternate ending
alternate ending yeah wow yeah I mean
that was I remember seeing in glorious
bastards in the theater and people just
applauding to Hitler getting shot and
you're like what a [__] weird movie
going moment where would you have to see
that movie that they didn't get Applause
how how deep in the South you have to go
before ah hero dies or Palestine but
yeah uh we saw D Jango in the theater
and we were like look at these white
people getting shot cuz you're so
wrapped up in it that you're just like
yeah Kill The Honky yeah it's
extraordinary he does feel like he gets
permission he gets like he has that kind
of um he's got a little backlash the
curb status but I think he's able to
kind of you know go through it it's it's
a weird thing like some people are
grandfathered in and actually if you had
to go through committee what you can say
on television now in a late night set or
whatever you know you just they go no no
you can't say that that exactly it's
nothing but people kind of it's a weird
thing I think like comedy lives in that
space between public and private
discourse like how how do people really
speak and how how like they speak on TV
no one speaks like that on you you watch
people on Good Morning America well no
one's having a conversation like that no
it's all HR over there and later on
we'll be baking cookies join us later on
we might be drunk we got traffic and
travel in a minut for the the pumpkin
spice lat so it's just what yeah we're
making park is grandfathered in if you
start in the 90s you can kind of still
get away with doing the [__] they've
done but it's it's very few people can
get away it feels like like uh a Family
Guy as well as just the WR on that are
fantastic the thing of uh they've got um
they've got a great podcast Have you
listened to that no um another a
typically disgusting display another
Seth McFarland no no it's not Seth
McFarland it's the writers on it it's
the sulk and um oh suk's funny I mean
just so good great podcast about it's uh
by writers for writers who hate writing
a great podcast
a typically disgusting display fantastic
podcast I'd really recom it okay I'll
check that out really fun just such
funny boys they do Johnny jokes the
beginning they do like they make
themselves do Johnny Carson style jokes
oh like a monologue like because they go
look we're writers and like it's Comics
as well you start off like reverse
engineering right how do I write jokes
yeah and then you they just like go okay
well let's let's do it every week as as
an exercise we're at five each hell yeah
it's really and it's sometimes terrible
and sometimes magnificent sure that's
some I mean sometimes I'll just write
headline jokes just to like get the
going yeah and you kind of that thing of
like that muscle of I'm working on a
thing at the moment where I'm I'm like
I'm trying to do a writing course to
teach people how to write jokes because
it feels like it's a bit of a lost art
it feels like people are there's a bit
too much magical thinking about it where
people kind of go oh well it just comes
to me and you like it's like people that
play music and they don't know how to
read music you it's better if you can
read it it's better if you know are how
to do it yeah the fundamentals that
thing of like getting back to headline
jokes you kind of write those and you're
kind of in that spin so then when
something happens in life you're kind of
you're thinking in joke formats that's
so cool because remember when you
started you were so lost you were like
how do I do this you'd read joke books
you'd watch comedians but that was about
it there wasn't really a tutorial or
anything slightly that kind of myth of
oh he's a genius he's a funny guy he's
just a funny guy he's well that guy's
just a genius no he sat down and wrote
that exactly Chris Rock is I would say
the goat for me the greatest ever we're
fans and you go you look at his material
you go you look at an hour special and
you go yeah there's seven hours that
didn't work yes that you can't see
exactly he tried in front of an audience
and went this is going to be good and it
didn't work and you you don't get to see
the working out thing of like the
reverse engineer we do see it sometimes
at the seller because he and I love
watching him at the comedy seller
because he just he doesn't do the loud
kind of Arena or theater Chris Rock
voice he doesn't do that kind of like
you know that Sam Kennison almost like
slam dunking joke he does he just like
talks out jokes he's talking at this
energy and that that's cool to watch but
it's interesting the the um the thing
I've kind of been working on is the on
performance is it's about 92 beats a
minute he's perfect 92 beats a minute
seems to be the right Rhythm for speech
if you're kind of hitting that word it's
I listen to a lot of songs that are 92
beats per minute preo on better show
like that in the pocket of that Rhythm
seems to be where spoken word Works
whether you're doing comedy or giving a
speech or whatever Obama's about 92
beats a minute as well right well
Seinfeld has that Rhythm where they
might just laugh because he stopped you
know what I mean it might might not be a
funny joke but what's the deal with
tables and then they'll laugh I've done
a thing where I'm doing like two shows
in a night and I do the wrong punch line
for a joke I've done it like a handful
of times but every time I remember and
it often gets a laugh it still works of
course because the the rhythm of the
people are like laughing before they've
because it's such a social activity but
you feel like a fraud when that happens
right oh I feel I feel like what are you
people even doing I know I know it feels
like there's a there's a a a glitch in
The Matrix yes yes hang on they would
have laughed anyway yeah I know it kind
of hurts it's that thing of like what
what laughter is that thing it's such a
social noise like you could watch the
best on your phone on the bus on the way
to work or on the subway the best comic
in me watch Chris's last special no it's
fun it's good yeah it's great but you go
and see it in an arena with 16,000
people it's ah you're laughing and you
release the Endorphin and the serotonin
it's like it's the perfect it's such a
social thing laughter as opposed to like
it's my Fe on why Thanksgiving or
Christmas in the UK TV is the best
because you watch it as a family oh so
that thing of like the difference
between your favorite movie like it's
Christmas movie we love it we watch it
every year and you watch it with five of
your family and you all laugh together
as opposed to the rest of the year
you're watching on your own it's so
funny you say that because I noticed
commercials will get a laugh in a group
commercials are the least funny thing on
the planet it's horrible writing but
you'll put like eight people together in
a room and a commercial comes on that's
humorous there'll be a chuckle but you
would never laugh at that alone yeah
it's also it's such a bummer that we
don't like I think of what you're saying
we don't really see comedy movies in the
theater anymore and some of my best
memories are like wow why do I like The
Hangover so much I saw it in the theater
and a ton of people were laughing Friday
night and it was packed and you were at
the that thing of like if you see it
like I remember my favorite thing about
when I started comedy when I like gave
up the day job and was being a com was
seeing movies in the day I kind of used
to love that thing of like going to the
cinema love like and it just felt like
freedom to me like I so into movies
remember I used to work and I used to
put in meetings like [__] meetings
at one at like 12:00 noon and one at
like 2:00 so I could go and see a movie
in Leicester Square in London and just
kind of come back to the office go yeah
I had a couple of meetings I'm back a
that's F kind of you remember the movies
that you that you want to see that would
have been like uh I don't know like I'm
just trying to think no I don't remember
kind of I love that freedom though era
yeah that that thing of like seeing them
in the movies is like such a I don't
know just feels special yeah and it's
kind of empty you kind of feel like you
have it all to yourself yeah it's it's
not quite the same as live think there's
a theory of you never forget who you've
seen live good or bad like you like
there's no sometimes you be halfway
through a movie on a plane and go have I
seen this like that back can hand with a
kind of nothing movie but you see
someone live it's like it's forever you
remember that thing it's such a big I
don't know I saw Cosby I dozed I forgot
the whole thing but I saw Cosby live in
Montreal about I it's got to be 15 years
ago now and it was a master class he's
one of the best it was it was really
interesting like how long he left it
between punchlines the kind of cadence
of his speech the way that he I mean I
think that thing of they did that
documentary and someone had the great
idea of going the artist formerly known
as Bill Cosby let's take if you can't
separate the artists from their work
really what are you but he was also
you're talking about music and beats per
minute Cosby was such a jazz guy too
there is something musical about that I
think I think we're living in I mean or
whatever I I talk about this a lot but
the that idea of like comedy is going
through something very special at the
moment we're so new this is such a new
thing you don't think it's going to
burst the boom we're in I don't I don't
think it started wo I hope you're right
I think Chris Rock is John the Baptist I
don't think Jesus is even here yet I
think it's like I think it's like a
different way of speaking so that that
comedy course thing of like going
teaching comedy I think it's going to be
I think we should be teaching in schools
is my don't give it away though you
don't want these these Rubes doing it
this is all we have think about what
what does comedy give like a young
person like you're trying to find your
voice what you do well that's what the
teenage years are about you're trying to
find like the idea like people saying
you know online I I don't feel
comfortable in my own skin as a teenager
you go yeah that's what being a teenager
is through part of their lifestyle they
have to learn that yeah but I'm saying
comedy gives you that right you we sort
of go through that as Comics you sort of
find your voice you didn't find your
style immediately and it kind of found
you you didn't choose to be the kind of
comic that you are right and stories and
it's just you are what you are like I'm
better at jokes than I am at stories I
try and write more standup now to kind
of work that muscle but it's like it's
not doesn't come as naturally as jokes
MH for me but it's like you find your
voice and then it's about performance
and and being able to communicate with
other people like there's so many things
that young people need I I think it be
legit after school activity I think it's
interesting I would also throw this in
the ring and I don't know how you feel
about this but I took an improv class in
college and I'm not an improv guy but
but I would go talk to girls at bars and
boy did it help or you go to a job
interview and you want to just be able
to go back and forth with the uh the
boss I think an improv class could could
uh Comfort yeah could teach some kids
something yeah it's like it's that kind
of self-confidence it's also like yes
anding it's a perspective right it's a
lot of perspective is comedy it's like
you step back from the awkward thing and
go this is going to be a funny story
later on I can see there's a bit of
perspective actually the lack of
perspective is where you get kind of
that anxiety do you think anything has
do cuz you say it's a sliver of window
between what people actually think and
what we're supposed to say was that you
said do you think there's anything to
the we don't go to movie theaters
anymore and laugh this is a way to
connect socially again we're all on our
phones we're all up our ass we're all on
apps I mean the comedy cell thing is you
know everyone has to put their phone in
an envelope yes and they they're annoyed
by it but I love it and it's so good for
them it's so good for even that bit
before the show when they have to have a
[__] conversation with their friend
or their date and go what's up and you
you see people in restaurants now and
they're both on their phone Googling and
you go they both want to be here but
they're both desperate for that dopamine
HIIT the new the new I once saw a guy
walk into the cellar and put a decoy
phone into the envelope and then he had
another phone or maybe just had two
phones I don't know decoy yeah two
phones that is a that is a drug dealer
or a pimp yeah right right what's the
second phone for never never you mind
his other family I don't know yeah
exactly but you're right but I think
younger people I don't want to
generalize I think they have one inkling
of discomfort and then they go to this
it's like a passfire so I think if you
can get over that maybe that's why the
crowd work thing is is so big right now
it's the only time you interact with
somebody yeah that that thing of uh I
don't it's is that thing like boredom
doesn't get enough credit bedom my
childhood was full of boredom and you'd
wait for the TV show and you sort of
think about the thing you remember is I
don't know whatever you watch when you
were a kid The A Team and you'd be
watching that and if if you missed it
you missed it and it was a moment in
time but you don't think of the boredom
before and after but actually that
boredom is kind of where your creative
mind comes from like the the gift of
boredom is huge with writing jokes be
bored be bored more often let your mind
wonder and then that thing of like
anxiety doesn't get the credit it
deserves anxiety is a huge part of my
kind of creative process cuz that thing
of like if you go if you've got your
mind woring the whole time I'll write
jokes that's something to do with your
mind right if if in the morning when I'm
not thinking about jokes I will just
I'll go into kind of um just thinking
about what's the worst case scenario
what's the what's the worst thing that
could happen in the world I'll be
creative about that it's also stressed I
mean sometimes you're stressed about
something the thing passes and then it's
like the floodgates open you're like
joke joke joke or premise at least
something you know I I mean I remember
Louie once said to me he calls the phone
the pipe he's like put down the [__]
pipe the jokes are written in the abyss
you have to be lonely you have to be
isolated and I I do think there's truth
to that oh yeah he's really he's really
jumped into that yeah the
pipe the um yeah it's it's interesting
that thing of like uh I mean it's always
it's always the thing every self-help
thing is it's always deferred
gratification yes like putting the fun
we did a thing on holiday a couple years
ago which sounds really kind of you know
me and the MS like put the phones in the
safe in the morning like you check you
check Princess Diana hasn't died you
check the big [__] big yeah you got
to keep up the day you check put it in
the safe and then you kind of have a at
6:00 in the evening orever we're in
Hawaii by the way your phone and your
gun in a in a safe how dangerous It is
Well it feels like we're like sometimes
when you sit down at a table like and
everyone puts their phones on the table
it does feel like the wild west yes
totally and then when you actually try
to remember the name of the movie the
actor without this guy Googling it you
know you use your mind it's like a
muscle totally I think people have that
there's that um what's it called the uh
Dunning Krueger you heard of the Dunning
krer effect that idea that people think
they know more than they know because
Google gives them a false they know so
people don't know what they don't know
right and they think they know yeah so
people being experts on you know if you
ask an expert on anything they go a it's
really complicated right but if you ask
someone that know you ask a cab driver
they go real simple here's what we're
going to do with the economy true true
but the cab driver thinks he's dumber
than the other guy but yet he knows more
these only fan stars are are putting
together the uh [__] Middle East
solution she has hot with her [__]
dad but she's got a two-state solution
you know they all got an opinion
everybody's got an opinion without the
research but have you heard that that
experiment about the leaving people in a
room alone with a buzzer and it shocks
you and if you leave someone in a room
long enough they'd rather be shocked
then feel the boredom so they'll just
hit it just to feel something and do
something and have something happen
whether that rather than just sitting
there having their own thoughts I mean
solitary confinement is the ultimate
punishment right well electric chair
then solitary yeah I think solitary is I
think solitary is like I think if we had
to do it I think would come out with a
with a one-man
show don't don't threaten us with that
give us a comedy show at least well the
onean show I was chatting to Mike bigly
about this and he made a great point
about how a onean show like a really
thoughtful one like okay it's a comedy
special oh no it's a oneman show that
what's the difference two moments where
you tell the
truth two moments where you go there's
no punch line at the end of this I'm not
undermining thing I'm just going to tell
the truth about this moment that's
that's enough that that's a oneman show
okay it's interesting that thing of like
you don't have to give that much in
terms of like a a heartfelt moment to
for it to kind of really I see what
you're saying it's emo comedy yeah what
it is you that's kind of an oxymore but
yeah that's a good point more punch
lines that's what we need thank you I'm
I'm a fan I mean Mark and I were like
you know Club Comics always we it was
always like you know I feel like the alt
rooms gave you a longer leash but but I
kind of liked having a short leash I
liked having to like be like Bam Bam
like I I felt uncomfortable if I wasn't
going to laugh yeah I think that like
that fast ball thing of like I'm all
fast balls and that thing of like you
you can you earn a story or I think you
earn a point as well you can make a
point if you have like if the punch
Line's big enough at the end and you've
got like there's a reason to say it and
and audiences are really smart like they
they get what's okay he's saying
something here and this is just a silly
joke they like they they get it people
kind of like when you read like when
someone gets canceled or whatever over a
joke you this is some nonsense the
audience knew what was going on there
right there's no hate in that fine yeah
it's like that bill ber thing you're mad
about the joke but they they put the
joke on the news they were in a comedy
club knowing it was jokes a big
difference big difference between
telling a joke to a theater full of
people at 9:00 in the evening and
shouting it through someone's letter box
at 900 a.m. which is what's going on on
Jesus exactly actually I think the last
two or three times I got canceled and
and there's been many occasions you kind
of look at the joke written down in the
paper and go GE who said oh I know I
said that right that seems a bit much
well to say was going to a porno theater
or a sex show and then showing the sex
show on Tik Tok like Jesus Christ but
there it was supposed to be there I had
a woman write a hit piece on me once and
she quoted one of the one of the bits
the only bit she quoted properly I was
like I think it holds up in text that's
a good sign but isn't it weird there's
no like comedy doesn't we don't have
books like there isn't a book of your
material no one's done like a I think
Seinfeld did it too but like was like
there was I mean you get to aor you get
to a level of uh they I Lov Sarah
Silverman's bit on mine Camp hit me with
it in the LA in the last special she
goes my struggle that's what it's called
My strugg I'm struggling it's like a new
take on that after how many jokes about
Hitler down he's a victim he's a
snowflake that's hilarious my gag on
Hitler was uh yeah you know not not all
bad he did kill Hitler
I mean give credit where credit is you
that's great if You' killed Hitler you'd
never stop talking about it it' be your
whole thing right right Dana G is a
great you saw the Dana G bit about
Hitler about how uh he was married for
just a few minutes and then killed
himself marriage is
hard I I've got a line in the new show
about um how people get more right-wing
as they get older it's a good thing
Hitler died when he
did that's good where was he going right
hey my Hitler bit was uh I thought he
was great all right okay that was
it joking joking but the fact you have
to say joking is like I know there's a
couple idiots out there that thing of
like this is kind of great like the
standup thing for you guys feels like
you guys since I last saw you actually I
haven't seen you since pre pandemic but
it feels like both of you have like like
popped oh thanks it feel like the last
specials or whatever the the the one
that got trans you did the one on
YouTube that got transferred to uh right
no I did another one on Netflix I did a
YouTube one but that first one was like
that felt that felt like that was like
the level up and then the the not a lot
of thank you man not a lot of people put
specials on YouTube at the time and uh
it I mean February 2020 a lot of people
are home you know for the next few
months uh no but I I don't think anyone
watched it cuz they were home and there
was no other media available I think it
was like a really good special it's like
it's also because of YouTube it's very
Word of Mouth even more so than Netflix
you kind you're kind of watch on the
phone or on the computer so you're kind
of messaging as you oh for with that to
my friend like it's it's an easier like
felt like totally it was something that
kind of spread out there and you s nuts
is fantastic but that really felt like
again that like it's like are you like
theaters now were you clubs what
theaters baby he just did the garden uh
theater theater I played that once it
was phenomenal it was a yeah it was a
cool night uh but you know seats right
it's like a proper sold it out yeah I'm
gonna hit clubs for the like December
through February just to tighten it for
another special but uh yeah it's been
theaters all year it's been it's kind of
amazing have you guys gone out together
CU I notic they a couple of people did a
thing we did it John John Stewart and
John melany went out and Pete yeah I saw
that and you kind of think it's quite an
interesting thing to kind of go there's
no one that likes your stuff that we go
I I like him I hate him there's like it
feels like it would be a an interesting
thing to do we get that I get that
request a lot when I do Q&A they're like
bring Sam out or how come you don't do a
show with Sam and it's just cuz we can
we don't have to split the money I
wonder though I wonder though if like
someone like John Stewart Pete and and
melany it's like three different kind of
generations of Comedy you know so I
think that might tap into something
different for them I don't know I just
think it's that thing of like it's it's
a oh he's on in town I might go and see
that like it it becomes like oh no we
have to go and see that look at Seinfeld
and gaffan they're out together now are
they yeah I mean that feels like an
embarrass harassment of riches Fant I
mean but I sort of hear that and go yeah
no I mean you'd have to go and see that
yeah clean comy bab you ever do that
with anyone I think I I mean I would I
certainly would I've been chatting to a
friend about it recently like that thing
of it's bigger than the sum of its parts
is that thing of you go well maybe
that's like an arena thing maybe that's
you play a bigger room and go well it's
a big event of an evening yeah Chappelle
and Rogan did a few of those yeah I did
like uh why did I do I saw Chappelle in
what was it January February we were in
Australia together and we and I opened
for him in uh in the Rod Laver Arena he
did like in the round wow I mean an
arena in the round so good there's no
bad seats yeah you could be slightly
more expensive to organize but you go if
you're in the middle it's like it's
smaller than the garden really in every
direction sure and you just kind of
rotate and it's same number you know
it's three screens above you and
everyone's got a great view do you find
it weird to rotate yeah a little bit but
you got used to it real fast I mean all
right great first time I saw you I think
was on the game show to distraction oh
yeah that was a funny show but they did
like a thing on distraction where they
did uh the American version they took
out all the funny and just did the game
show in the UK version it was like it
was like a a really funny show I mean
you got you got your lines in as my
point you know it was uh it was crazy it
was the uh yeah look well this is going
to be some years ago at 5 11 what
year 13 years ago it says on YouTube but
who knows when they uploaded it I think
it was a lot longer than that wow
hello and welcome distraction the show
where we distract people as we wow baby
face Jimmy kiml looks terrible is being
handed over to the Iraqi people and the
iraqi's new foreign minister has
promised him a fair and unbiased trial
followed by an execution on July
1st pretty oh let's stop this
I that's a good joke solid it's a lot of
yeah I don't know I don't know I made a
lot of Telly over the years that always
felt like a side Hustle the TV feels
like someone else is going to make a
decision one they go y we've had enough
of you right I'll just stand here CU
that thing about like the cancellation
thing is all about stakeholders that's
the key thing with cancellation who are
your stakeholders whove you got like if
your management walk out on you or the
TV company goes we're not working with
you anymore that's the cancellation
thing yeah you don't want too much of
that going on you want your own your own
independent yeah well that's why we work
with writers sometimes and I can tell
the writers like oh what are you crazy
and I'm like that's a great line they're
like yeah but we can't I'm like oh you
have a job you have a boss you have a
tax return and all that like we are so
connected to the audience we're like no
that line killed in Pittsburgh and
they're like you can't [__] put that
out there I'm like no I already did it's
done it's out there it's on the internet
yeah I have a I'm doing a Fallon at some
point and they're like oh you got to cut
that you got to cut that I'm like I'm
just not going to do it I mean these
lines murder they they're I put them in
because they work so what's the point of
me got harder for sure to just getting
jokes approved I mean you're probably
you've done so much I find I mean I've
done a lot of I haven't done one
recently but the the late night I tend
to get like I do it when I if I have a
new Netflix uh you do like a a Fallon
whatever it's such a thrill to do those
shows but you go out of an hour I can
maybe get five minutes of clean stuff
yeah you know you go because I don't
really write that stuff a lot because
you you go well you sort of go to
where you know you want you want ants
put down sugar you know what's the
reward and the reward is the big laugh
the big Goring I shouldn't be laugh
laughing at that but I'm laughing at
that it's such a sweet laugh yes and you
go well you can do stuff that's more
familyfriendly occasionally you come up
with something that's just would work
but it's not really my sense of humor
right but it's almost kind of an
exercise like let me see if I can dodge
these laser beams and still kill so it's
kind of an exercise but it's also like
ah is this what's the point I'm not
being me yeah so I don't know maybe I'll
work around it who knows when have you
got it when have you well it's just
we're still in the in the the the
material phase of like cut that keep
that so I'm still massaging it but it
makes you just want to drop it all when
they're like that's not going to that's
not going to fly and I'm like it's a
joke about homeless people they're like
e homeless people might hear it I'm like
they're not going to hear it they're
going most they could lip read through
through a window through a Radio Shack
window yeah can you say homeless anymore
it's like it's it's uh unhoused unhoused
who knows still condescending to yeah
it's like they we're changing changing
the words as well doesn't make any
difference it's like I've seen homeless
people they're not politically correct
no I had a line about um yeah like the
PC thing doesn't get to the underlying
issue it's just virtue singing so if you
go it's really diverse around here lock
the car
doors is is like that's as bad that's
the most RAC sure didn't change anything
doesn't make it better doesn't make it
better like a sex worker I'm still
peeing in her mouth you know just
calling her a sex worker is it going to
help this help this poor woman's
situation God lover oh yeah sweet girl
miss your Aunt Rose but uh yeah nice
lady the best line on that um uh Patrice
God Rest s had the best line on that
like he found out he was um
diabetic oh yes from from peeing in his
girl's mouth tastes like birthday Kake
sorry your pee tastes like birthday Kake
you got to go and see a doctor it's like
that is that's real love birthday King
is so funny I listened to Mr P recently
um so good it's so good yeah I got to
work with him a little bit in uh in
Montreal scary some shows yeah genuinely
like like if you travel a lot like we do
it can be hard to fall asleep in an
unfamiliar place or if you just have a
drinking problem right if you find
yourself up all night long wondering if
your hotel room is haunted it's time to
check out beam beam's dream powder is
actually a healthy hot chocolate that'll
put you right to sleep I use it it
actually really helps me haven't really
gotten those weird nightmares which I
would get on uh what do you call
melatonin always get those it is nano
CBD and all other ingredients all
natural to knock you out without making
you feel gr hogy the next day we might
be drunk listeners get a special
discount on beam's dream powder for
their bestselling healthy hot cocoa for
sleep with no added sugar now available
uh in delicious seasonal flavors like
cinnamon Cacao is that right sea salt
caramel I'd like can I get some sea salt
caramel I like this stuff and white
chocolate peppermint better sleep has
never tasted better a recent clinical
study revealed dream help 93% of users
wake up more refresh and 93% the dream
help them get a a more restful night
sleep and you know me I got the drilling
of my home I want to kill these people
it's awful if something terrible
happened to them that I didn't okay that
would probably be legal don't really you
understand my anger if you want to try
beam's bestselling dream powder take
advantage of their biggest sale of the
year and get up to 50% off for a limited
time when you go to shop beam.com drunk
the discount is auto apply to checkout
no code necessary that shop
beam.com drunk for 50% off it's very
good stuff I I use this and I I endorse
it figuring out out the perfect gift for
someone can be hard not anymore with
this plate you can turn anyone's hobby
passion or even the most embarrassing
photo in a highquality metal poster it's
fun for a prank too right displates take
just 20 seconds to install will not
damage your house they come with a
magnet that sticks right to the wall
then display it sticks to the magnet
easy as that yeah uh these I haven't
used but they look actually awesome and
uh and they have all these cool licens
design like Star Wars stranger things
Sports all that type of stuff so uh they
have what you need to make the season
bright makes a great gift and you can
save up to 30% off when you click the
link and the shows notes discount
discount will uh be automatically
applied to your cart when you click the
link or use code drunk when you visit
display.com that's displate.com code
drunk or click the link in our shows
notes great gift and uh they got a lot
of fun stuff they got back to school I
think as well which is one of my fav you
know I love Rodney it's a it's a cool
gift check it out but so [__] good oh
yeah you guys get along yeah I mean
great I think it was like a different
world world's colliding you know kind of
I was pretty pretty new and kind of
doing a nasty show thing and it was he
was yeah who else was on the nasty show
with who else was you know he moved
toasty show was like moved to England
for three years because he said he
wasn't hitting in America and he's like
I just need to go to England just to
work out yeah it's an interesting thing
that I I think when if comedy ever gets
you know we've got the best job in the
world but sometimes you you don't
realize because you're doing it every
day sure so that thing of like traveling
more is I don't I kind of the American
Comics I think are slightly they wait
till their really high status to go out
to the rest of the world but go early
you think you can't sell tickets it's
hard with the flights and the HS I think
it's I think you can sell tickets now I
think it's like there's a weird thing
where you go there's a there's a certain
thing about the podcast and the Netflix
thing it's gone Global so you can but
those new Comics aren't on Netflix in
the podcast well I'm saying you guys you
guys should be traveling the world you
guys should be doing Europe I'm going
Australia this weekend is amazing where
you going where you playing uh Sydney
Melbourne Brisbane Adelaide that's it
right yeah I did it in January January
February great crowds it's unbelievable
it's it's so great you're going to have
a blast I'm nervous the flight stresses
me
out class from here 20 something hours
yeah you stopping on the stopping on the
stopping in uh I believe San Francisco
that's what I did I I did it one once
the first time I ever went I was kind of
nervous about that so I flew to from
London to Vegas
two day two three days in Vegas which is
all you ever need in Vegas yeah and
because it's the same day again and
again oh yeah and then flew to Hawaii
had like 4 days in Hawaii and then flew
to Australia it was like the per cuz
there's no jetl you're kind of 8 hours 8
hours 8 hours they tried to get me to
stop in Hawaii but I'm on the road so
much this year I was like let's just I'm
going I'm coming back I need I need some
time in New York and Maui's not what he
used to
be what's the so how long you going for
you going to like 10 days that's a
pretty short trip short who 11 maybe I
don't know wow you're getting in and out
it's like a heist I'm just gone every
week I I just if I can if I can get like
another week in New York I just need I'm
I'm never here yeah it's it's a weird
thing when you I mean I've got kids now
so it's that thing of like trying to
tour in a different way so you get more
time when you want I mean it's great for
being because the UK I can kind of be
home every night right even if you're
you know Manchester or Newcastle
whereever you can get back and be up
with kids but it's just it's a sleep
deprivation game rather than a flight
away so it's a bit easier I've started
doing two shows a night as well everyone
to I love two a night yeah 7 and 9:30 I
think it works for people as well
they're kind of that you either get
drinks in dinner before or afterwards it
works right do you are you sleep
deprived a lot yeah I would say yeah
same mafel I would strongly recommend o
what's this cuz I can't Mel no okay so
my friend with narpy turned it on I am
not a doctor this is not a medical
recommendation we're just guys talking
about pharmaceuticals just chatting MF
is it was invented by the French
military in the' 70s so they were trying
to come up with something that wasn't
amphetamine to let their soldiers go for
longer so like to go for 72 hours
straight so they started using it with
people with narcolepsy in the uh in the
late '70s early ' 80s and it's got no
side effects it's not like coffee or
you're not like shaky and jittery or
whatever but you can just function for
longer so if you don't sleep like when
you get up when you wake up like 6:00 in
the morning oh this is an upper yeah
take 200 milligrams of that and then
you're good for the day you could
perform whatever you need to do for the
day but I can't sleep this is going to
ruin me no but if you can't s you sort
of do that and then you you have like a
full day great and then you'll sort of
sleep afterwards I see you'll be fine it
doesn't affect your ability so what have
you got a sleep disorder or are you I
just you know I don't know I'm a mess I
think it's just work doing shows at
night just adrenaline can't yeah yeah
it's a it's a it's a big thing though
like if you're not getting kind of 8
hours if you're not kind of properly cuz
all the REM stuff from sleep all of the
stuff that really does you good is
between 6 and 8 hours yeah so it's like
it's that thing if you're not getting
eight hours then you're not ever really
getting that I've drilling like for the
last 14 months Jack hammering I'm I'm
losing my mind I'm I'm losing my mind
just I mean it's crazy you're doing okay
you got a little bit of gold move it's a
beautiful apartment and it's I you
bought it yeah ah they pulled the wool
it's like he married a trans person
didn't know it last minute how long
that's not the comb I would give it how
long's the how long's the building been
going on apparently it's been happening
for like 3 years it's some corrupt city
[__] called section 11 where the
construction companies just make a
killing section is never good
csection Jewish section what are they
buing they're it's trying to make sure
the bricks along the you know cuz it's a
crazy City lawsuit if a brick comes
loose Falls and kills someone on the
street yeah but I'm like dude three
years you could build a [__] building
what are you doing so they're just
jackhammering and it's all right sorry
and we're back it was it was a long
story and we're back I I farted on my
girlfriend the other night and she goes
you know I don't want to date Mark
Norman that should be a bumper stier I
think I think she probably does I think
that's but the but but that lack of like
I they for whatever reason they weren't
doing it today I'm in a great mood
yesterday I was like I want to [__]
kill myself it's crazy just lack of
sleep is it dude sleep is everything
it's there it's a superpower it is yeah
it's tough It's uh by the way these
hubman all these guys are like you need
eight hours of sleep if you don't get it
you're going to you're going to die then
he's like get up at 5:00 a.m. you got to
get up at 5:00 start your day start
working do a to-do list start working
out I'm like which one is it do I sleep
for eight hours do I wake up at 5 well I
think they waking up at 5 is for the
next day I think if you wake up at 5 and
have a full day then next night you will
sleep do I go to bed at 8 p.m. yeah I
don't know I mean that it's tough these
guys they they're virgins yeah seem seem
all of those guys get up very early I'm
sure what that's about have you seen
wg's thing it's like oh well they're
getting up in the morning and yeah but
that's and 30 minutes he's praying it's
called [__] it's in the thing I I
work out I pray for 30 minutes I feel
like you can cut out the pray what you
we okay without the prayer come on pray
at night what's the difference God
doesn't care I mean yeah the morning
routine is it's just to make everyone
feel bad about the that's what it is
that's what it is you get up you write a
novel you do your taxes you do 12
push-ups yeah and then you have a a
weird athletic greens I do I do that
every day I have those I do too actually
wake up 2:30 a.m 2:30 you see these
people are insane do they have wives I
mean that's just jetl isn't it he's just
on a different time zone I hope so he's
basically living in the wrong time zone
he needs to move 8 Hour an 8 hour flight
away yeah all right well he looks
different now too I think he needs some
sleep yeah do you are you like a big
exercise guy on the road too you're thin
as a fiddle I can't exercise on the road
I've got like if I'm at home I can do it
but the idea of like someone going to
the gym in the hotel I think that's like
a superpower unlik bringing sweaty
clothes in your hand luggage H please I
can't do it I walk a lot when I'm if I'm
on the road huge just walking and kind
of thinking that thing is like that
seems to be very good for you like the
10,000 steps thing seems pretty good and
pretty easy to do especially if you're
in a strange city you I'll go out and
I'll at least see it and see what's
going on and you got the audio book
going and they say walking boosts
creativity it boosts your mood it's
great for yeah it seems to be seems to
be pretty good for you sorry on the road
just seems impossible is that a lot of
your writing is just like because Norman
Paces yeah you you you do you sit yeah
do you do you walk I do I sit and do
work when I'm kind of traveling on
trains or planes or whatever and it's
that's the editing process so the
writing is just whenever anything comes
to you when you're kind of walking
around having lunch on your own
constantly writing down ideas thoughts
there a thing there's a thing there's a
thing and then you the the editing or
sitting down trying to work out well how
does that work I've got like a a couple
of bits I I I brought in a couple of
bits I know the podcast but that thing
of like things I'm trying to do at the
moment yeah where I'm trying to get it
uh to organized to yeah like trying to
get it to like what it's a fun idea but
it doesn't quite work you have to convey
it to them in a comedic way you can't
just say this thing happened like biglia
has this great trick that I always use
where he goes you're writing and he goes
now where would you laugh and it makes
you go oh [__] I thought I was just a
funny guy who could talk on stage but
when you're actually writing and looking
at what you wrote and go where would you
laugh it makes it real it's objective
now it's not it's interesting when you
try it on stage and you get the laugh in
a place you didn't think you would get
the laugh oh that's a bummer yeah I mean
I'll take it but it's sometimes it's
good though cuz you're like oh sh well
you're just getting extra laughs you
know sure but the ones you thought would
hit didn't and you're like oh I don't
understand this art form [__] I've Got a
Theory at the moment about body count
I'm working on this bit about body count
so people talk about body count the
amount of people they've been with oh
yeah and then you got it's not about
that that's if you want to moralize I
I've got no problem with anyone's body
count but if you want to moralize it
should be about the rejection rate
because if a girl is a 10 like a stone
cold smoke show model gorgeous every guy
she's ever met has hit on that girl yes
everyone right so and and then she's got
a body count of 30 but that's pretty
that's pretty pretty good like it is
hard to get in she is Harvard
right right whereas actually if a girl
if a girl is a is a um is a is a swamp
donkey a munter like [__] she's a
she's a three at best okay like a [__]
horrible looking and she's got a body
count of five she's not more only five
guys ever asked everyone [__] got it
oh that's a great it's a kind of
interesting like per yeah what's the
what's the thing trying to find the
right thing and I think that's like a
joke that that'll be built on phras
yes it'll be the right term like you
know sometimes it's like it's a joke and
sometimes it's like a turn of phrase
that's really sticky that's a nice
what's the term for ugly that's going to
be the thing that's and then that thing
of like going if if a girl is a if a
girl is a 10 she's a smoke show she's
gorgeous like a model no one in here but
you you've seen them there that thing of
like
that like there'll be something along
the way that gets it I think it's like
it's an interesting idea but it's not
kind of there yet and it's longer form
because normally I'm in such a rush to
get to the punch line that's long form
for you cuz that feels pretty quick oh
that I've heard him do like I've heard
him do like 20w jokes yeah yeah I mean
even like dwarf shortage yeah
that's little Brad Williams action yeah
that'll do yeah I gotta oh interesting
I'm trying to blow out more cuz I my
writing it's so quick as well and it
takes so long to write an hour well we
had the thing we had an exchange when
when Soup To Nuts came out cuz I I've
just taped my special and I watch Soup
To Nuts and and we have the same joke
and it's it's like so we we have the
same joke and it's really interesting
because it's the same comedic I could
tell we wrote it in pretty much the same
way and yours is three words and mine is
like the end of a bit and it's like
really I've dressed it up right I've
like I'm so dressed up the bit but it's
basically the same gag yeah it's good
thanks well you know well we'll be we'll
be we'll be in trou when it yeah we'll
get trashed it'll be yeah yeah this guy
stole from oh I can't wait I had it out
first just saying but uh but yeah but no
it's see you're across the pond it's
flattering yeah it's uh it's it's good
it's kind of it's normally annoying but
I called you on my AR can I is it all
right if I keep it in sure I had a
similar thing you know Danny jalis he's
a funny comic La guy he did a really
interesting thing with with his uh last
special where it's like a Choose Your
Own Adventure so he'll say like teachers
suck and then I'll be like or are they
good and you can choose which way he
goes so he
on how teachers are great and the other
how they suck and you every premise he
does both angles it's kind of I think in
a great routine though you can kind of
hit both of those things you can kind of
go from each but also you know the best
example of that the Jim Jeff gun bit
it's like a 15-minute bit but he hits
this angle that angle defends it hurts
it it's great but he doesn't do guns are
great I guess that's true you know I
mean so it's like you know you can kind
of have your cake and eat it a lot of
the time as well because you kind of go
well you have that
as well sure the probably why there's so
many Comics who are lawyers Demitri
Martin Geraldo alel yeah it's just
pleading your case like hey I'm winning
I'm winning this what what was the bit
what my bit the Danny J oh we had a
similar bit about how we're all trying
to be inclusive got to have diversity
but no one gives porn the love for how
diverse it's been for decades
interracial gay trans lesbian you know
[__] animal all that so he had a
similar take and I called him and I was
like is this too close and he was like I
think you're good so yeah yeah it's I
mean as long as everyone's cool as long
there's no there's no kind of oh I think
you straight lifted that like no it's
obvious um have you ever had a guy
really lift from you yeah blatant yeah
like there's like an old school comic in
the UK did like a a full bit of mine but
I think it's just ah I'll write
something new I write a lot of he still
15 seconds yeah it is that thing as well
where you kind of go it's a big deal
when you start out if someone takes a
bit of yours but then you if you're if
you're writing enough if you're writing
kind of a thousand jokes a year you get
less precious about the material I think
initially when you've got like your
first 20 minutes it's so precious of
course and then when you go well you
you're you're the gun the jokes of the
bullets and you have they're kind of
disposable you're kind of going you've
heard the Louie story with Dennis ly do
you know that I'm an
[__] that was a Louis bitou and then
Louis saw him do it and Dennis L is a
bigger comic in Boston so he was like oh
I guess he took that bit that's gone and
then like 12 years later they were on a
o Anda together and Dennis Le just gave
him 20 grand and he was like sorry about
that did he really yeah and Lou was like
all right but he had to just drop it he
was like it was one of my big bits and
then this guy made a huge hit song out
of that bit and he just had to drop it
and he did it with Bill Hicks oh Dennis
ly yeah the Bill Hicks thing is uh
there's a story about the Bill Hicks at
the very end when he was dying gave up
smoking like four weeks before he died
and then want why you why you are giving
up smoking and he went well I figure if
I do it Dennis
lir giving the kid a break damn pretty
hot I mean love it Zing him on the death
bed get the man of
water whatever you got yeah thank you
man Christ This Guy's staring huge huge
demanding it about the bits I'm working
on what are you guys working on what
bits have you got uhoh I got one I tried
last night I'm like treading very
cautious ly with the stuff in the Middle
East but I tried one last night I think
there's something here maybe about like
look I'm a Jew I mean it's a thing I
know I could pass both but I am a Jew
and like I have a thing about how like
actually yeah I think they could they
could all vote for you yeah maybe you
should be the lead because really I feel
like that could have gone either way I'm
covering the bases here but the angle is
like how like look as a Jew I have to
admit we have a we have a hand in the
media and uh and basically I don't I
don't I mean I don't want to I don't
want to den the podcast I'm currently on
but a hand in the media get over
yourself I'm softening I'm softening the
setup Jimmy I'm soften they're
controlling the media this my friend is
not Fox News I think we what you don't
think we we have some hand saying more
than a hand no I'm saying this this
podcast it was right um so it is a
little with the I tried yesterday is
like you will see like headline like on
the news it'll be like you know 7,000
Palestinian babies murder and then like
the lead story is man on the upper west
side tears down a poster n and you're
like yeah both are bad right one is one
is worse yeah I mean but posters that is
annoying like to go to Kos you got to
[__] you know that's true the tape is
not cheap tape is not cheap you got to
put it up prining got tape is not
cheap so this is like I think this is a
start of something I think is there
something on the posters yeah there's
something on the posters which is listen
it's too soon and all that but at some
stage someone could do something on the
look I get it if your cat is missing you
put up a poster yeah in the neighborhood
yeah don't put it up 6,000 mil away oh
good who's help who's oh well I guess
there's a missing person I'll look but
I'm on the upper west side I think if
they're here they're safe yeah that's
true yeah the the the hostages is like I
don't think we're going to run into them
yeah ex yeah I don't know it feels like
it's that thing where you go that
there's there'll be something something
that comes out of that and I always
think jokes are a really good um uh
barometer for what like the things you
can't joke about like certainly in Great
Britain if once there's been some level
of Justice once you're through something
then the jokes you can kind of process
it and if there if something still feels
like it's ongoing it's like it's
difficult to kind of of course yeah no
there's there's no relief laugh yet yeah
so that's why I can't that's why it's
like okay we'll see we we'll do this one
in a few months I'm putting hopefully a
few I mean whenever [__] there's
relief that's one great thing about the
internet is I have a couple Hamas Jewish
bits and in the room they're like ah and
I put it online and it they killed no
pun intended but it just it blew up
online no pun intended but uh it
murdered but it it did great online
because you don't have to worry about
the guy next to you how you're reacting
you you can just enjoy it and I think
there's something to that with darker
jokes sometimes the internet is weirdly
better and worse right cuz you do deal
with the people that are like almost
like walking in the room like what but
you do get the people that are like oh
this is my type of Comedy yeah yeah it's
like porn they can't look at it in the
office but at home and [__] they can
look at it yeah well you it's that yeah
it's a weird one isn't it one someone
you've always got something that you go
right you can't joke about this thing
yes like everything else in your set was
fine but that joke was terrible I was
think when you know on the last special
whatever I got in trouble for and joking
you go yeah but did you not see the rest
of it
the 45 minutes leading up to that one in
trouble it was a joke about um gypsies
yeah joke about gypsies but I mean it
was like it was it was a weird thing
where you kind of go um you you you know
you tell a joke and it's about like
about the Holocaust and the and and
flagging up the fact that uh I said you
know 6 million Jewish people died in the
Holocaust it's the it's the worst thing
that's ever happened and no one talks
about the hundreds of thousands of
gypsies that die in the Holocaust
because no one ever wants to talk about
the positives
but it's that thing of like it's pretty
clearly the joke is a misdirect also but
it's such a clear misdirect as well and
the but written down it's like oh this
guy doesn't care about Gypsies and you
go no hang and also a lot of the people
online I suspect did not know that the
gypsies di in the Holocaust or did not
know that homosexuals or disabled people
were killed in vast numbers by the Nazis
and it's and they're moralizing and they
just found out from me and you go ah I
don't [__] know the see of lion
people it's like didn't give a [__]
yesterday but today this is like front
page news for you yeah I mean that's
hilar I forgot about them that thing of
like I I'm sure there are worse things
in that special I'm sure if you if you
go through it you go worst holocaust
joke ever I think I've told you this
before Junior stopka that's a good joke
it's a great joke he's like uh you know
there was a lot of down syndrome people
that were in the Holocaust as well but
there's no photos of them because
they're all
smiling a good B that's a very good but
a lot of the jok I think your joke is
about the MISD and I think and like you
know the right turn I I remember used to
have a joke back in the day where I say
you know my ex never made me wear a
condom cuz she was on the pill ambian
that was a joke yes but like there's a
way you could be like that's a rape joke
it's about the misdirect of course also
I must say that Sam was heckled at MSG
this weekend by his ex from like 15
years ago yeah I told this before we got
here yeah what where she was the one
ambient
no uh what did I my my f first ever
holocaust joke was the um the they say
there safety in numbers tell that to six
million juw that's fun they're very
clean I I mean it's it's one of those
things Joan Rivers had the best line on
it Joan Rivers was I think she was doing
like a casino show and she told a
holocaust joke and someone got up and
walked out and made a real fuss of
getting a documentary and she and she
goes uh you say never forget this is how
I remember oh
and I think it's really especially with
what's going on in the world today you
go no no joking about these things
talking about these things how else are
we going to remember cuz on this podcast
we're definitely not making serious
points but those jokes are no this the
worst thing that ever happened L we
forget let's talk about it let's talk
about it all the time we're bringing
awareness I used to have a Hitler joke
uh he was bad with money he he didn't uh
he was he wasn't good at saving and I
was like man it's too bad there wasn't a
group of people that could have
helped
what's that great this is an old no this
is anonymous maybe you can find the guy
who wrote this but uh he goes go dies in
owitz goes up to heaven and he sees God
and he goes God I got a I got a great I
got a great holocaust joke and he goes
ah it's not funny and he goes I guess
you had to be there yeah no it's it's
TRD it's an old TRD joke it's a great
joke Trad yeah it's an old I mean that's
an old it's been around since like the
50s that is brilliant it's a brilliant
line I think Javas tells it to Seinfeld
car that's where I heard it uh but it's
a brilliant I had to pause it I was like
it's like it's almost like it's one of
those things where it's almost like uh
you know sometimes you get a joke that's
kind of got some wisdom in it I guess
you had to be there oh man well you took
a star punch line and you said something
kind of deep yes you exactly which is
kind of fun too yeah it's but you're
right people pick and choose I did a
joke in Kentucky with the
RW and this lady comes up she's like I
have a Down syndrome niece blah blah
blah you got to take that out of your
act and I go how' you feel about the
Holocaust stuff she goes that I loved so
you're like oh it's just when it's your
thing yeah it's yeah it's it's when it's
your thing but Al it's also that thing
of you go it is the the release valve
the amount of times you get people that
the joke is ostensibly about something
and they're so glad to be recognized and
you know if you great and people are
going for Relief right they're going to
they're going to escape I think they're
going to a stand up show so when when
the one thing does land on them
sometimes they don't take it well that's
remember the bill ber thing on the
morning show where she's like do you
really need to do the pedophile priest
stuff and he goes do you think the
priests need to do it yeah you know like
I'm doing the joke they're doing the
thing no she goes didn't do you think
you went a little too far don't you
think they went a little too far was my
favorite gag on that was the why would
you become an Islamic fundamentalist
suicide bomber on the off chance you
might get 72 virgins when you die become
a Catholic priest and have them now
that's good fun by the way teachers [__]
more kids than priests fun fact yeah
take that to the
bank
that's but the oh this is great too this
is a whole different thing but it's just
not related to what we're talking about
either and funny P it up she basically
says they women funny and he's like can
you follow me that's all you got to
worry about start your own [__] stop
stop worrying about the it's pretty
great all right I got a bit here go on
all right it's a two-parter so feel free
to kick me in the balls here on either
part so my lady she's a real Tom Cat in
the sack and she likes being insulted in
theed what year is
it she's a real tomat in the it's the
early 50s yeah she's a real hotoda B has
a similar bit go
on different dick but uh so she's you
know she's a she's feisty in the in the
budoir you know she's fun in the sheets
but she uh she likes being insulted in
the bedroom but nobody told me that the
insults are supposed to be sexy so we're
going at it I'm like ah you can't cook
and that hits and and she's like what
I'm like oh yeah you [__] and she's like
thank you and I'm like uh that needs
more I think but then I I flip and I go
I'm the opposite I'm already too
insecure I like being compliment in the
bedroom but they're all she's very full
of [__] with her compliments she she'll
be like oh you're so huge and I'm so bad
at dirty talk and I was like uh so are
you and that hits but it just feels like
two on liners back to back there's no
real point to
it so it's hitting but it it feels like
it it there's no meat to it it's just
two quick lines well you you firstly
your girlfriend is dynamite in the sack
a real a real Tom Cat I would have said
oh yeah I think it'd be on the it's on
the insult isn't it so what's the insult
what's What's the phrase you use what's
the uh uh I say you can't cook no no but
what's the What's the phrase that gets
you into it so she likes dirty talk she
likes to be she likes to be insulted in
the bedroom but nobody tells you that
the insults are supposed to be sexy so
you can't just insult her sex sexual she
want be called a [__] a dirty girl I
think it's the I think you got it the
wrong way I think it's like you go maybe
you the [__] and the dirty girl and bad
girl all that
first and then you build up and and you
can't cook and you can't parallel park
and you you you talk too much you
whatever the thing is you don't make
enough money I'm caring us yeah keep
going that should be the turn yeah that
should be the turn Okay up cuz I think
the dirty talks quite funny of the
you're a bad girl you're a bad girl
feels like that could be the turn you
you're you're a bad girl I think right
yeah your personal hygiene's not great
that's a funny L I think you need a
different deodorant it's but you're
saying do all that and then the can't
cook yeah I think they it's the build
got it cuz I think that's quite funny to
hear that kind of the dirty talk of what
people say to each other in the bedroom
is funny anyway cuz out of context it's
just like oh that that line of the you
know whatever all right I'll try it
tonight but then what's the what's the
insult to you you want she compliments
me but it's all lies she'll be like
you're so huge you know she's trying to
be nice while we're banging and I'm so
bad at dirty talk that I panicked I said
so are you calling her fat yeah I think
that kind that kind of works does that
hits it's a nice way out it's a nice
little button on the whole
thing and it and it Val it validates or
justifies that I'm I am actually
horrible in with the dirty talk sounds
like you're bad with small talk like
you're trying to have small talk with
her in bed and it's coming out dirty
like so are you that's what you say
right right you're butcher right back at
you yeah I was trying to give it back oh
yeah maybe that's a a better way to say
it because I also don't want to touch on
Regan's uh have a good flight you too
yeah I don't think I'm so worried about
that but I what else do men like being
told in the bedroom it's kind of it's
you're the best you're the best I've
ever had you're yeah you're so good but
then if I say so are you that's not yeah
that's not weird but you keep that but
maybe it's oh add to it uh I had a girl
once I had had a bit about a girl I was
with shouted uh Daddy when having having
sex with her and I was I was out that
window like a
shop he going to wake the
family there's some kind of something in
there yeah definitely yeah I know that
girl yeah just trying to yeah it's good
all right all right I'll try that that
that twist the other I'm trying work on
at the moment let me can help with this
the um uh crazy is a numbers game okay
so something being crazy it's about if
enough people get involved in it with
something crazy it's okay religion is
the go-to example so religion enough
people believe in Christianity that it's
Scientology it's crazy right they don't
have the numbers as soon as they get to
a certain number it's not crazy anymore
it becomes legitimate yeah but it kind
of goes for lots of other things as well
kind goes with with like [__] pickle
ball the first eight guys playing pickle
ball the [__] are you guys doing play a
real sport but gets to a certain number
this is absolutely legitimate I think
that's that's a great premise there's
something in the premise but I can't
quite figure out where I'm going cuz the
religious thing is like you you the
takedown of that pretty so start with
Scientology right and go well they
believe Z and Vol say violence is the
only difference it's like a mass shooter
you're [__] crazy a war we have to do
this m M that's that's interesting
That's good I've noticed if you're
working out murder if you murder one
person it looks real bad drop a bomb ah
we had this was we had to do this that's
that's interesting it's for our country
taking out the notepad this is big yeah
yeah no no that's that's good that's
interesting school shooting to war is
Big um does it it's kind of the flip you
can flip it with an
orgy you know sex with one
person
normal sex and an orgy I guess that's
also normal I'm just adding
numbers all right bad example I think
there there's something in that right
there's something in the but I think
that idea of like crazy as a numbers
game like the things in our society that
are clear it almost goes to all
observational comedy which is kind of
going the world is mad but the stuff
that we think is absolutely acceptable
so like tattoos tattoos used to like a
facial tattoo when Mike Tyson got his
facial tattoo it was [__] crazy
people lost their minds you know Mike
Tyson got a facial he's
Forever This is insane and now a facial
tattoo is oh cool it's like someone
bought a new t-shirt right it used to be
you were a badass if you had a now it's
nothing yeah I'd say regular tattoos
were like that like Sailors and you know
Fighters had tattoos and now every
Barista chick has a tattoo I did one
other laston I could try and this is a
new one date a girl who I used to date a
girl who had night terrors which was is
uh I mean it's terrible you get woken up
with just uh who was the first angle I
had you get woken up by just shrieking
you know so uh and it sucks you have to
be like oh man this uh I'm so sorry this
happened to you you know and she's like
it's really unhealthy to to wake up that
way I'm like I know I'm also waking up
that way right right that was the first
I think I I do a joke before that yeah
going no no so the the the the gag would
be I used to date a girl that had night
terrors she would wake up screaming iess
guess she wasn't expecting to see me
there oh almost like you can kind of
have that as a throwaway before you get
to the I had one other thing let me find
that's good I had one other thing throw
in a rape joke before you start might as
well um night tears is funnyim would it
be funny in that uh call me daddy joke
if you're were like quiet you'll wake
your mother rather than the
family like you're [__] a kid yeah
well cuz she saying call me daddy maybe
I I dropped it there was another joke
that had like it was you know sometimes
where you write two things that are kind
of in the same area you go that one's
better it's just yeah
yeah by the way I saw you the the line I
added on I said uh oh thanks man I added
on I said uh I did a go with night teror
that's when you wake up screaming which
is it's kind of weird she's a white girl
from the suburb she didn't serve in N
right that was the first
part uh she would tell me
where pink Berry doesn't have a flavor
yeah what yeah like talking to a dog
what's wrong girl they're out of Ros
yeah Lululemon's
closed um yeah there's something else I
said one other thing last night I got to
I got to listen with the set yeah
there's something to that there's
something with day Terrors you know like
you you worried about other stuff you
know it's why are you you're just scared
at night when nothing's happening other
people are scared like people live in a
bad neighborhood you know they have day
tears I don't know I think there's
there's something waking up
screaming yeah you're waking up the same
way that if there was like a burglar
with a knife but she's like oh no it
just it was just a dream yeah like
you're making up [__] to be scared about
other people are scared about real [__]
yeah you're being scared in a dream okay
I I had another we helped with that at
all I I I I said some stuff I'll listen
to uh dating apps yeah are all based on
the same premise right they're all based
on birds of a feather flock together
right so it's match.com everyone
matching up with people that you've got
lot but that's not the only way the
world works the world also works on
Opposites Attract and I'm going to start
a website I'm going to make a fortune
it's going to be called mismatch do.com
and I'm going to put people you know so
it's going to she's a she's a socialite
um daughter of a billionaire he's a
plumber from Brooklyn sure you put him
together and then I think the gag is
he's a he's a guy from Palestine she's a
nice Jewish girl when they met that
thing of like they like the weirdest
couple
think that's the
G and aive the idea that dating sites
are based on that premise of oh I like
that movie you like that movie maybe we
should [__] what yeah that's yeah why
would that be a thing you're thinking of
friends she's anti she's antifa he storm
the capital exactly give it a chance
yeah you know he's a cop he she's black
you know yeah those I mean they're very
American uh
the yeah but is interesting those things
of like couples you where where you
would go to the wedding and there would
be no question of bride or groom you go
I think I know
mhm something to the the Israel
Palestine like a it's a good it's like a
soft way to go into the joke I it's like
it's I think it's funny and it's
something everyone's thinking
about yeah that's but I like the whole
the bigger point of I I I kind of coming
back to your thing of like you could be
Palestinian or or Israeli the look I
think there's something you should run
for office in the Middle East and just
never name who you're talking about I
don't like these guys oh we got do about
you know who what they've done is
unacceptable and I I know you all agree
with me when I say we got to stop those
[__] I'm going to call them
[__] cuz they are [__]
and you never come down on either side I
don't care who I upset yeah I don't care
who I'm going say it yeah this this has
got to
stop that's funny yeah he put the the
middle in Middle East you're right down
the
middle yeah
you down the middle yeah that's fun
something there we'll shoot that sketch
when you leave we'll shoot
it uh yeah any peeves you have any pet
peeves pet oh yeah I got pet I was
thinking about the other day uh again I
Feel Like Comics we airport material
Hotel material we talk too much about
being on the road but people checking
out of hotels kills me I know me
just if you're listening to this I'm
going to save you hours of your life you
never have to check out of a hotel
you're not you didn't stay at their
house you're not saying goodbye to
friends and air kissing just leave just
[__] leave they don't need the
plastic key back if you want throw it at
the desk but don't queue up with your
bags when I'm trying to check in and
spend 20 minutes going through your oh
the itemized bill I see everything's
correct right oh I forgot I had a muffin
oh okay they the hotels have never got
anything wrong they've never mischarged
you yeah I even enjoy you know there
sometimes there's a little box that you
put the key in like check out box you
put the key in that I'll still throw it
in the garbage I won't even put it in
the Box [__] it there's no CH I'm not
I'm not giving you the satisfaction I'm
just leaving yeah a good it's a it's
just so annoying it's an it shows an
it's Amateur hour oh you're checking out
come on I think people that never travel
bug us cuz we travel so [__] much
totally yes I think that thing of like
you've got your
the meth what you mean you're in the
wrong boarding group you didn't know ah
I know you ever see people walk down the
aisle of an airplane and they're like
eight nine 10 like what are we doing
here you're at 11 just go to 11 you
don't know numbers yeah 911 but yeah
it's silly it's your lucky
seat the uh yeah that's that's a that's
a big peeve I'm trying to think if for
PE good one the checkout is silly these
people what what other the peeves you
got what else what else you other than
your I got this guy he's the laziest guy
I know but he's like man and he's like
oh you're writing a movie huh I've been
working on this movie for 18 years I'm
like no no you started to write a Title
18 years ago you never touched it again
and now you get to say you worked on it
for 18 years you didn't work on it for
18 years you worked on it for six
minutes and never again but that was 18
years ago that's not working on
something for 18 years does you see my
point yeah no one's reacting I know I
had to the someone had a thing recently
uh can you Google this it was the not
doing the thing not not doing the thing
it like someone came this list of like
things that aren't doing the thing which
kind of goes back to being stoic of like
talking about doing the thing isn't
doing the thing that's why we don't want
to talk about our movie any I don't want
to go into detail cuz I don't know how
long this is going to take it might be
years it's not doing the thing it's like
it's like a list on uh it's a really
good list actually it's on no it's on
hang on let me let me find it for you
hang on I've got it somewhere um but you
can't get the credit for working on
something for 20 years if you just
started it 20 years ago and never did
anything else you see what I'm saying
also maybe work on a second screenplay
obviously yeah some do something write
one page but not even one page is
written but he's been working on it for
years it's his life's work I can't find
this thing
uh this is this is great righta
um this is like the date you describ s I
have a real talent where I can throw
something out and no one responds to it
I don't know what it is no it's this is
small okay it's um uh strangest Loop oh
yeah I got it things that aren't doing
the thing it's a great list I think this
is like I read this quite a lot okay
hang on what do you got preparing to do
the thing isn't doing the thing
scheduling time to do the thing isn't
doing the thing making a to-do list for
the thing isn't doing the thing telling
people you're going to do the thing
isn't doing the thing messaging friends
who may or may not be doing the thing
isn't doing the thing right it just goes
on but it's so great for like it's gold
just like I always think new comics
there's so much of that going on you go
just jokes just do it just do the jokes
yeah so much of this is just like being
a CEO though you're just like do this
and they're like okay I know but I know
a guy I'm not going to say any names his
whole Instagram is him in a coffee shop
with a pen and a pad and a coffee and
he's like M and he's he's like I'm
writing all I do is write same act the
last 20 years same act you know the guy
the guy who's always has to write out
his entire set and you're like you've
been doing the same jokes he like I
can't talk to anybody let me just exact
I now it's pretty religiously this year
and it uh it really it's really paid off
the I do new jokes at the end of every
show so every show theater whatever
doesn't matter how big the room is I'll
do it tonight get out piece of paper at
the end and it forces you during the day
because you feel like such a dick if
it's stuff from last week CU you go
right do it Bank it once it's worked
like three times I could Bank it and
then that's going to be in the next show
yes but you kind of figure well it's
it's okay so you're burning through new
stuff at like 5 minutes a night and then
you're kind of banking that for the next
show it seems to be such a good way of
kind of working that muscle and
constantly cuz sometimes you you know my
tours are like three years long and you
could write the show and do nothing for
three years oh start start with a blank
piece of paper and it seems I've kind of
done that before and it's crazy it's
crazy now you got to prepare you got to
do it and that's a good way to do it is
to make sure the audience they're your
your motivation because you're like I
can't come with nothing yeah you know
you need you need to put
against the cliff like that or else
would do the same [__] for the rest of
your life I had like it's I don't think
it's a peeve but I think it's like a
it's an idea like we had a lot of
strikes in the UK this year like people
you know inflation's gone through the
roof so people need more money and they
you know working jobs and they're not
getting paid enough and food prices are
going up okay so you got to strike same
here okay so but what they do is they go
the guys on the train strike and they
don't turn up to work mhm but they're on
the picket line so they're not sitting
at home doing nothing they're on the
picket line striking so we're saying
what they should do if you're on a train
strike you open the ticket booths and
you let people go in for free for the
day oh because that hurts your boss but
it doesn't hurt your customers that's
good cuz you haven't got a problem with
your customers the guys riding the
subway are riding the subway the guys
riding the trains are riding the trains
but you go but [__] with your boss's
money yeah see they take that more
seriously is that
legal probably okay I don't know what
the law would be that would that would
prevent that yeah I guess yeah but no I
like it I mean that's way more effective
yeah because then you see some some
results yeah yeah we had that with the
Auto Workers they just stri and they won
good on them yeah everybody's striking
now the actor striking the writer a lot
of striking I didn't realize it was
because of inflation are the are the
actors still striking now yeah well by
the time this comes out probably not I
would say who knows this coming out in
2026 but uh yeah Jimmy why don't you
plug can we plug gigs oh you got you got
a hard out no I've got it's not that
hard out I'm flying now okay Boston I'm
fing but the um this is very fun I've uh
current tour US states yeah there you go
I don't know why I'm playing tell me
what is good tell me what's good on
these days okay soost
tonight 26 so starting December okay oh
yeah I put in like double shows in
December so I've got I've got to sell
these hard so people of San Diego great
theater yeah that's a great theater
that's good okay right in the Heart of
the City what am I the Wilton wil wil's
nice La cool never been to the Grove
National Grove in Anaheim on the 8th of
December anaheim's a cool area two shows
two shows in Anaheim Disney okay and
I've never heard of the city at all
that's a casino okay good luck casinos
are tough is it yeah usually okay so how
is it tough in the casino I don't think
I played play casinos in like South
Africa they've gotten better they've
gotten better but if you do the club at
a casino you're toast but the theater is
pretty good cuz people actually came out
to see you the club had to buy a ticket
away okay that'll be fine it'll be it'll
be fine and you'll get a nice room and
then Mesa Arizona on the 10th shows
watch out Trump country the Paramount da
on there this weekend badass theater two
shows shows okay cool and then the new
Mark theater December 14th in Portland
Oregon last time I went to Portland it
was like it was I mean it was like
apocalyptic it was like The Walking Dead
it was like it was crazy well it's
gotten worse oh yeah a lot of tents it's
rough how would they fentanyl babe they
did the uh free drugs or whatever crial
that's all drugs so it's not like
illegal but it's not it's it's weird but
they did that in Portugal and it's
really worked yeah but what they did in
Portugal was they decriminalized all the
drugs this is like 15 years ago they did
this in Portugal decriminalized all the
drugs but then what they did was really
smart all the money they were spending
fighting the drug war they spent on
rehabs and education and they all that
money they ring fenced it and they went
okay it's linked to inflation we're
going to spend that money every year on
making this [__] okay cuz most people
that are on heroin don't really want to
be on heroin they'd rather not be on
heroin there's a hardcore that will
remain but they get it for free now from
the pharmacy they get heroin for free
not methadone it kind of works I think I
get a prescription on the road recently
I was like yeah some of these cities
you're like o That's CVS area oh my
great I noticed that I mean the other
pet peeve in New York the last couple of
days my my other half was here with me
and we're like shopping we're in a CVS
they're locking up the toothpaste now
yes the stuff they're locking up now you
go it used to be razors were locked up
the razor was like they was I mean those
guys at Gillette please how much are you
charging for a I mean L99 whatever that
thing is it's crazy but the they'd
locked those up but now they're locking
up [__] chewing gum oh yeah yeah well
the the the the grab and steel or
whatever you call it what do you call
those Smash and grab yeah I think it
really started during Co when it was
just they just would steal everything
and people were like yeah but I'm going
to importantly get some manfa deal or
whatever the hell you said oh yeah I'm
going to pick up a bottle of that I'm
pretty sure I'm pronouncing that wrong
this schedule's amazing 13th 14 14 15th
16th 17th is incredible San Francisco on
the 16th I've just doneas I think last
Sunday I celebrated my 250th theater
show this year good lord well the more
theater in Seattle is like maybe the
coolest theater one of the great it's
like it's like the best you're going to
love it it's beautiful it's huge it's
three tiar but they're I can fill it but
not with
laughter explain this December 16th San
Francisco San Francisco and the 16th in
Las Vegas oh that's that's March
oh de
March jump there yeah big jump big jump
not bad yeah veg is Vegas going to be
all right Vegas is cool it's not my
favorite I'm going to I'm going to fly
and I'm going to go and see that YouTu
show I think yeah I really want to see
it who's the first comic that's going to
do that I I I think Hannah gadsby
Chappelle maybe I text Chappelle the
other day and said how come you haven't
played the sphere what's going on CU he
could do he's like he can sell infinite
tickets oh yeah I would say he should
just do a residency right he's doing the
Iron Dome oh my
God nice all right Mark do you want your
dates uh sure what you playing I'm mism
match.com that's my website you don't
say there we go Paramount this weekend
oh yeah we're uh 25th all right I can't
read that [__] sorry blow that puppy
right up will you yeah I think it does
feel like there's a weird thing with
American versus British Comics we get to
theaters a bit faster we kind of leave
the clubs a bit faster cuz we've got
such a nice theat circuit you get on
that theat yeah we get to laughter
quicker but I know what you mean all
right Jesus all right all right just
joking their car we got the Sanger
theater on November 24th in Mobile oo
the Orum on the 25th of November Orleans
big big Hometown show Luther Bank Center
for the Arts that's December 1st Santa
Rosa that's sold out I believe the Crest
theater two shows in
sacrament uh Omaha uh Kansas City
Norfolk Baltimore you you know Markman
comedy.com Tampa Theater Florida theater
when when are these uh when are you
going International maybe that's what
you guys should do
together but the international stuff you
just did it I just did Europe I did a I
did a full Lisbon Dublin Birmingham
Manchester Hackney I went all over yeah
um I think that'd be a good plan though
because the travel is like it be that
would be the fun thing to do that's true
together like to go okay we're go and do
like the far if you do Singapore Hong
Kong I've got about in January Singapore
Hong all that stuff book in those rooms
the lady boy tour yeah that's not bad
that's good you don't hear a lot about
the lady boys since trans happened
they're not getting the shine no they
really yeah you're right when did you
last hear the FR chicks with dicks it's
been a minute it has been a while right
I wonder if they're pissed like hey you
took our whole thing it's like a cars
when they did the horses yeah you I got
a Vegas
what horses did to cars that's what I me
I got the win in Vegas December 2nd
that'll be fun then we got uh Tampa uh
Tampa Theater the Fort Myers oh man
we're doing the same gigs yeah and then
uh and then I'm going back to clubs for
a while just to tighten this for the
next special and the write some new [__]
where you going to take the special uh
the The Wilbur Boston Beauty great Club
oh theater feels like a club more
specials have been taped there than any
theater in America another one that's
got the tables down the front yeah it's
pretty bad I love it yeah and then you
know Buffalo Springfield Madison Philly
Dania Beach Omaha Dallas OKC Irvine Salt
Lake and then the special so I'll see
you guys on the road wo and this new
hour is cooking thanks so check it out
folks um get some Bodega cat whiskey get
wh where's where's the bodega cat
whiskey it's up on the bar somewhere
bodegacat whiskey.com it's go see I'm
sure a lot of you already know Jimmy but
uh go see Jimmy on the road man great J
maybe maybe check count the Netflix
special first see if it's for you it's
not for everyone is it oh come on this
is but account this is you got a you
know I got a whiskey no really I got a
whiskey with um uh with like two two two
like weird a weird group got together
it's called Uh muff
licker muff licker that's fun it's
there's a town outside Dublin called
muff H and there's a Distillery there
called muff liquor did you do it just
for the name just for the name I love it
I love just for the dumb name but we've
got like um that's a cool battle yeah we
got the Vodka Jin and whiskey but I did
it with like uh it's like me and Russell
Crow and Ed shearan it's a really OD mix
invested in pretty cool good booze I
mean like the the vodka and jy's winning
Awards yeah it's Jim Crow all
right there it is muff liquor muff
liquor that's great I mean it's a good
name that's a fun name I went to Ball
State so that'd be a different
liquor
all right thanks for listening guys
thanks Jimmy it's a pleasure it's good
to see you guys great
[Music]
stuff a
too Up on the Roof like a cop's coming
and naked Samuel is feeling dangerous
I'm out to lunch here in New Orleans
this woman doesn't look like I
remember and I get down in the same
way we
might
be